On screen you were seeing Arson
Ostrophyski. Not only was he a survivor
in the recent attack, get this. Arson
Ostrophyski also survived the terror
attack of October 7th.
Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his sword is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, umrahra, salah, fasting, what?
No sodak. Brothers and sisters, Ayera is
getting thousands of shahadas monthly,
yearly. Hundreds of thousands of people
are coming to Islam. They are printing
Quran, distributing material, training
duat. Brothers and sisters, do you want
the part of that goes on forever. This
is how Islam has spread around the
world. Brothers and sisters, carry on
this legacy of the prophet in donating
whatever amount in support right now in
enjoy the video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
hope you guys are winning. So, as you
guys know, we exposed Patrick Pet David,
the absolute scumbag, intellectual
[__] absolute fraud, the Ponzi scheme
artist. That's what he's known for. So,
alhamdulillah, brothers and sisters,
they are in utter shock that a Muslim
done what Islam tells him to do to save
lives. Alhamdulillah. And that's what he
done. But brothers and sisters, Candace
Owens spoke about this about a week ago
and the screenshot you see in front of
me, clearly saying that there will be a
911 style attack in December. Yes. And
uh lo and behold uh that's exactly what
happened. Now it gets more peculiar and
more weirder as we speak about it
because now we are seeing how Israel the
Zionist Mossad are operating and how
they work. Yes, you get an idea. Number
one, the first thing first is this dirt
bag. Let's go to this dirt bag cuz this
gets really really bizarre and
interesting here. So here is this guy on
screen. You were seeing Arson
Ostrophyski. Not only was he a survivor
in the recent attack, get this. Arson
Ostravki also survived the terror attack
of October 7th. What that officially
proves is he is on par with his luck
similar to that of Larry Silverstein.
Arson also went on some news media
outlets and he quoted, "We came here
only 2 weeks ago to work with the Jewish
community to fight anti-semitism. I
never thought I would see it in [music]
Australia." So he survives October 7th.
He survives Bondai Beach. And then also
get this, let's jump back over to Naveid
Aram, who is one of the shooters in the
[music] attack. This obviously took
place in Australia where they are
heavily regulated with firearms. In the
videos that have surfaced, he obviously
has clear skill and people are wondering
where that came from. Well, there are
reports going around stating that Naveiv
Aram was a former IDF soldier who was
deployed and in Gaza who just recently
came over to Australia.
>> Okay. So, obviously like I said before
about that Navidid Aram guy. Um, again,
I don't believe Mossad are that stupid.
Yes, I know they're stupid, but not that
stupid to the degree that this guy's
going to be an Israeli, etc. I think
it's fake. Okay, so we should not spread
fake news. And this one about the makeup
that's been done before, which I'll just
go to the video to show uh this it's AI
image. Yes. Okay. This that he's this
guy um who apparently survived October
7th and then survived this. It's all
orchestrated. These guys you see many
plants even when the Charlie Cook
shooting, this very same guy who was a
witness or there at 911 was there as
well. It's not coincidence. These guys
work in this manner. They are pulling
the strings. These Zionists, these
absolute scums are pulling the strings
on all these attacks that happen around
the world. They have attacked USS
Liberty. Yes. U JF Kennedy. Yes. Um
Charlie Kirk. Everyone knows it's a
hidden. It's an open secret. Okay. So,
this video we're going to go to which is
an AI fake. Let's just go to some fake
stuff and debunk them. mate. Right now,
this image right here has now just
started circling the internet. And come
on. Now, I'm not going to lie, this
is just unbelievable, [music] but
believable because we know that they
stage events to push narratives and
tighten security grips. Let's say, you
know, the digital ID surveillance
systems. [music] So, I asked Chat GPT, I
said, "Is this image real?" It said yes
this is a real image a behind the scenes
photo from a film [music] TV production.
From what I know that is fake. Okay. So
now the question that we need to ask is
how is that? And not only that we look
at the graph Navidid Aram's name was
searched in Israel a day before or a
couple of days before the shooting
happening.
You can't make out and now Facebook I'm
not mistaken or Google they have shut
that down. You can't make that search.
So the question we need to ask is very
simple. Yeah. Candace Owens who is
anti-Zionist, anti-Israel, makes a
prophecy. We're going to call it
whatever is for that matter comes to be.
You have a shooter. Yes, they plan
accession, whatever for matter. I
genuinely believe the most plausible
thing is this. They have these people on
their radar. They know what they're
about. They know they can shut them down
and arrest them and stop that attack
from happening. They let it happen on
purpose. This is what I believe. I don't
believe in this whole like they're part
of No, no, no. I believe the most
plausible explanation is they have them
on their radar. They know what they're
about. They know what they're capable of
doing. They know what they're going to
do. They control their messages. They
they they they observe their messages.
We're going to do this or whatever. So,
they're like, "Okay, we know they're
going to do an attack." Let them do it.
Turn a blind eye like they did with
October 7th standown order. Let it
happen. Why? Cuz they use it for the
agenda. Okay. This is a false flag
attack. That's what that's the most
plausible thing. Not is a Zionist idea
soldier. No. Yes. He could have easily
trained himself with that gun. So, the
most plausible thing is they let that
happen. And guess what happened? They
planned and Allah plans and Allah is the
best of planners. a Muslim Ahmed al-
Ahmed came to the rescue and destroyed
their whole narrative. So much so the
Australian presidents come and said to
me Natario, "Stick your head out of our
politics. You scumbag." Okay, so in a
nutshell, follow Candace closely because
she's going to be having an interview
with Charlie Kirk's wife who I believe
was a part of all of this. Okay, she is
the way she's mourning his death and the
way she's being, you know, the sexual
innuendos, the way she's touching this
other guy. Absolute weirdo. Absolute
weirdo. and her connections to Romania
of a child charity uh uh for children
and then it was for use for
exploitation, you name it. These people
are dark people. So, brothers and
sisters, Candace Owens is exposing all
of this. Follow her closely and believe
me, they want her out and they're going
to take her out. So, we ask Allah to
guide to Islam. You can see goodness in
her. And brothers and sisters, I will be
keeping you guys up to date as things
unfold. Inshallah, till next time.
ketu.